Hi, my name is Ikai Lan.
Welcome to another edition
of YouTube Developers Live.
Right now, today I'll be
showing you guys some tricks
that I have when I'm
working with the Player API,
and I've been trying to
either debug some issues
or share some code with
some people on my team.
So let's go ahead and
switch over to my laptop.
Those of you that have
been using Player API
are probably used to seeing
this reference by now.
This is what I always go to.
This and the JavaScript API,
these are reference docs
that I'm commonly using when
I'm working with the Player API.
I'm also frequently using
the YouTube player demo,
because this lets me see all the
different options that I have.
But what this
doesn't do very well
is allow me to
share these options
and to share customizations as
well as edit them in real time.
Now, those of you
that have been doing
web development for a while
know that in Chrome, Firefox
you can click Inspect Element.
And you have the entire DOM
tree available in these tools.
You can also access everything
via the JavaScript console.
And this is really nice,
because you can run and test
JavaScript.
Oops, that's invalid
JavaScript code.
And it's a REPL that you
can use to test your code
and make sure things
are working correctly.
Now, I'm going to take
it one step further
and talk about some of the
tools that we use on the team
that we think are pretty cool.
And these are online
JavaScript IDEs.
A few of us-- Jeff and I,
in particular-- we really
like using a tool
called jsFiddle.
Now, jsFiddle, this
is a really cool tool
that lets you specify HTML as
well as JavaScript to go ahead
and test and run your code.
So this, we've got a very
basic Flash Player here.
And you'll see that in this code
I've created a link element.
I'm using jQuery.
And you can load jQuery
over, as on the side
you could say, well, which
JavaScript library do
I want to auto load?
I'm saying that once we click,
I want to start the video,
so I'm going to click
the Test Me link.
And it starts playing the video.
And that's really cool.
Now, I can't stop
this, unfortunately.
So what I'm going
to do now is I'm
going to go ahead and-- let
me turn the volume down.
I'm going to go ahead
and click Update
once I've made
changes to my code.
And now I have a
link that I can copy.
I can right-click, copy, and I
can email this to my coworkers
or other friends who can just
open that code up and start
testing it.
And every time you make
a change in this code,
you can click Update.
Now, this isn't meant to be
a tutorial about jsFiddle.
This is meant to show you some
of the cool tools and tricks
that we use.
So you can go ahead and search
for a tutorial on jsFiddle
on your favorite video site.
That is, of course, YouTube.
When I was looking, I found
several good tutorials
on jsFiddle.
That's the basics of it.
You can also do things like tidy
up the code, run a JSLinter.
And there's just a lot of
different options that you have
when you're working
with jsFiddle.
And of course, everything also
works with the basic console.
If I were to inspect Element
and go to the Console,
I could have this function
do a console at log.
I would click Run,
and that's what
it would do to update
the HTML in JavaScript.
Click Run, and you
would see that it's
logged into JavaScript Console.
So make use of all tools
that are available.
Now I'm going to
switch over real quick.
That was the Flash player.
I'm going to show you
the IFrame player.
This IFrame player
looks very similar.
This is-- I basically ported
most of this code that's
on the IFrame API
reference over.
So when I take a look at this
code, it's pretty verbose.
So I've taken the headers.
I've loaded the script source.
Now, the IFrame player reference
loads this asynchronously.
I'm just forcing it
to load synchronously.
I'm creating a div.
And I'm just creating
a test element here.
I'm going to click Test Me.
And that'll start playing the
video, and that's really good.
That's really cool.
So over here, again,
because I load the source,
I can load on YouTube
IFrame API Ready.
And because I've
also loaded jQuery,
I can just start using
jQuery's functions
to make my life easier.
So once I'm done with this code,
if I'm able to reproduce a bug
here, it's-- especially, if
we're following bugs against
our public issues tracker.
And if you don't know where
that is, it's at YouTube-- oops.
You search for
YouTube API issues,
it's this link, gdata-issues.
Kind of an old name
for an issues tracker.
But we still use this.
We look at this.
And this is a good way
for you to file bugs
and to file what you expect
and what you observe.
And those are the bug reports
that help us out the most.
So that was all I had
to show you today.
I just wanted to show
you that it was possible.
And if one of the questions we
usually get is, are we hiring?
The answer is yes.
Check us out at
developers.google.com/jobs.
That's all I have
for you guys today.
And thank you for
tuning in today.